Hey how's it going bros.
My name is Pewdiepie !
As you can see,
i'm going somewhere,
I'm going to Italy, tomorrow.
uugh....
had a busy day
trying to get videos ready
in advance, for you guysss
God dammit
you don't deserve it
but I thought i would vlog
along the way
it's been a while since i did a vlog,
Smash that like button if you
*awkward sounds*
like vlogs!
Also, check out the giveaway
that i'm doing
$100 Amazon gift card,
ugh but
euugh
That's it, i'll see you
*dank music*
Heyyyy
I got some problems with the memory card,
but we're going to
pisa???
Marzia: Yes
we're going to pizza
for some pizza and
pizza??
can i squeez-a
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
your titsa
your tits-a
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
M: Wow..
got'em
Got'em
Okay we're going to pisa
It probably looks like shit
and sounds like shit
because my camera broke
Here's my camera bros
I were in em- keep forgetting where we
yes at this bar that's cool right this
call hmm am i doing it what am i doing
in Apple am i doing it now there's
bunnies in this garden that we don't
know why please love me
you think you'll like this okay pick
honey please please love me
okay
whatever I don't care whatever bunnies
it working it's working now Hey
and we're matching day - we're still in
Pisa but we're going - I'll get it
via Nigel let's go it's so trippy it
looks like it's moving I feel motion
sick just looking at it. This is amazing
It's more fun to look at the
tourists than the actual buildings
Wait look at this I'm old now aah oh my god I look
like my dad oh my god I'm so young what
about a girl damn damn
let's see Marzia old what no difference
Bobby eyes whoa those waves are huge
we're at the beach now I don't know why
or what we're doing I don't speak
Italian so I'm just following along trying
to understand what people are saying but
we're here now
yeah boy I'm taking you to the water
I think I'm JimBob like no one's
watching oh my god I'm falling
what'd ya say hey Marzia I made you a
playlist
Oh wow thank you. You're welcome
oh my god what am I doing here what's
happening
good ride you picked there. Are you jealous of my sweet ride? That's pretty
good can I come on board, is there room for
one more
no wow oh my god you think I'll die okay
yeah boy oh oh shit that was scary too
fast for me
No nooo noo
so we kind of we kind of snuck up on the
ceiling until we get caught got an
amazing view though
so apparently it's low season right now
this is not a lot of people apparently
I'm so sick of people, there's too many
people here, there's so many like student
groups as well and they see me and
it gets crazy
oh my god they got married down there
we should spit on them Marzia
welcome to the final day of Felix has
no idea what's going on vlogs we're in a
new city now and that's about all I know
having a great time actually really
liked the architecture architecture
looks cool
this Hill is crazy I wonder if I can sit
on the bag and then go down is it
safe
no terribly if I drop my bag here it
will kill someone alright now it's going
upwards instead of downwards god dammit this is so annoying
thank you Marzia for the help
appreciate it
okay so now we're at the dome very
pretty cool we now we seen I'm just kidding
it's very but very very pretty
do you like it pretty it's good right
you have a bug on your that's how I roll
can I get a liquorice I've been hooked on
these liquorice but they seriously turn my
saliva into like poop
I just got yelled at by Marzia my god
Marzia we're gonna be rich boy look
at all that money
no more Youtube no more Youtube for Pewdiepie
this is the final vlog guys and the
final vid do you ever feel like a plastic
bag sweeping through the wind wanting to start again
so here we are and it's so tiny it's so
small oh my god it smells so bad
smells like I I shit my pants I don't
want to go in there it's terrible I think I
changed my mind
so it's supposed to be like a hot spring
but it's more like a shit smelling spring
all right let's check out the
temperature all meal deal it's so hot
it's actually pretty hot it's actually pretty
nice I can get down with it
okay I don't really want to go because
it smells like shit but I will go anyway
Should I drink it? No? You dont think it's safe?
farting but no one knows now you tell them all
that was pretty nice did you like it
Marzia now excuse me while I join
the dark side was that cringy yes
okay thank you all right last day in
Italy is over we're traveling back home
tomorrow to see the pugs
I'm so happy to be home
it feels so good it was a nice trip but
nothing like good old sweet home now
we're going to get the pugs but yeah I
hope you enjoyed this vlog I feel so
ready to just get back to making videos
I don't know when this video goes up but
the time times are weird right now on
YouTube like there's a lot of issues
with a lot of things I
feel like it was good for me to get a
break from it but now coming back I'm
fucking ready leave a like everyone
smash that like button let's can we get
a couple hundred